die chino hosen sind die verbrechen
gegen die menschheit was er gemacht hat
mit mann maus ist hier und das ist
wirklich alles andere als einfach also
hatte ich das am besten so aber ich
glaube ich hab mich verguckt mir ist
aufgefallen dass mega drive ist wenn man
kein auto hat also ohne witz ich muss
mich mit michael gleich treffen
jetzt muss ich überlegen nämlich ein
taxi was halt voll teuer ist oder fahre
ich mit der bahn
da muss sich vor lang laufen oder ich
laufe kompletten das dauert
ähnlichkeiten ich hatte erst überlegt ob
ich ein car to go nehme aber das darf
ich ja theoretisch gar nicht weil ich
bin ja ein kleines leben und die kann ja
kein auto fahren aber vielleicht wer
weiß wenn sie jetzt mit meinem auto
gefahren ist vielleicht will sie dann
auch unbedingt über schein machen und
wird sich auch eins jetzt muss ich
irgendwie mir überlegen wie ich dahin
komme keine ahnung ich mache ich auf
jeden fall ist auf dem weg und überlegt
mir einfach beim weg runter okay ich
sage jetzt erst mal tschüss zu meiner
neuen wohnungen und trefflich wird malki
wir können uns später noch mal dass mir
eingefallen die ganzen kleinen details
so angucken das heißt gesehen kelly
hatte einem cap von mir auf das heißt
sie war schon an meinem kleiderschrank
und wir kommen uns ein klarer schritt
auch an und wer weiß was wir uns alles
hier angucken ich gehe jetzt aber
erstmal los treibt mit nike und auch
diese ganze studio sache und so was dass
wir später singen gehen
das wird alles nicht so einfach aber es
ist ein geiles video und dafür lohnt
sich ab geht's
käme es jetzt im moment hier der pick &
cloppenburg da treffen wir uns und dann
werde ich ausgestattet gerade ganz von
der seite angekommen ohne was zu sagen
prinz charming lokal tätig ich bin
gespannt hier leute da sind hier das boc
jede menge sagt der höchstwahrscheinlich
nicht gefallen zum größten teil bedienen
ist
wir werden das jetzt wieso sollen wir
wollen ja dass du das fragen stand soll
ein ein ja gerne vermelden uns
dankeschön
deswegen ist es so ein weißes und
klassik weiter mit aber das ist schon ne
genau das so ein bisschen lernen
war hier dass das würde sowohl luther zu
passen oder china und oben la
dunkelblauen opel haben eigentlich auch
neue schuhe zu teuer werden einfach den
sport sagt nur in dunkelblau dann geht
es rund und so eine chino hose ohne wird
sich findet chino hosen sind und
verbrechen gegen die menschheit
eigentlich aber ich bin zu ihnen passt
sebastian hat immer so kinos angab hatte
nur solche an und dann ein bisschen
verboten
ja genau
[Musik]
vorher und nachher
gucken dass man als reaktion an
das heißt du bist so schön
diese fans gar nicht so schlecht aus
super ist auch nicht leicht das so nach
rechts noch yachtclub da hattest du mit
champagner
wir finden noch die rotex ist was als
nächstes die rolle freund leute
irgendwie gar nicht schlecht kommentar
frage was ist besser
das davor oder das hier du bist doch
entschieden oder ja deshalb möchte die
länge ist auch gut ich glaube die rose
nämlich wirklich mal mit so weil die
kosten ist eine so teuer aber das sagt
kostet 300 euro oder so und das hemd
auch teurer ist es auch richtig cool
aber 300 euro ist zu viel
schade eigentlich ja ich finde das schon
gut bist du zufrieden mit seiner
leistung
das ging schnell vor allem so zweiten
fall immer meine pension wenn ich jemand
redeweise ich an dich die kleinen auch
interessant geschnitten mit dem wiso mit
diesen großen taschen und okay leute wir
sind jetzt raus ich habe nur die chino
hose gekauft weil alles andere wirklich
so teuer das hemd 90 euro das der sakko
das 300 und nehme das war mit die wir
gehen jetzt nochmal zu zara und checken
da ab ob es irgendwie was ähnliches gibt
dann bin ich umgestellt und muss dann
auch schon langsam nicht auf den weg zu
machen ins studio wo ich dann singe mit
meinen umstyling klamotten ich glaube
nicht letzte schlimmer wird sylvia kälin
anstrengendes leben
wobei ich sah es heute so da und hab'
ich kuchen gegessen während sie bei mir
in der uni war auch nervig
das ist okay ich hatte die nase haben zu
drei vierteln oder das wieder das wird
einfach so gemacht damit man sieht was
es kann
genau
[Musik]
gebt euch hier vom waxing so richtig rot
so wir sind jetzt raus ich hab ich grad
die sache nochmal eingeblendet die ich
jetzt gekauft habe also sakko und hemd
schuhe kaufe ich mir keine mehr weil ich
habe halt schuhe und bevor ich mir jetzt
so günstige kaufe weil ich wäre es halt
nicht so viel geld ausgeben dann nehme
ich dann lieber die ich muss jetzt aber
auch glaube ich wie gesagt direkt schon
zur achim so ein anstrengender tag kelly
sind deine tage wirklich immer so
anstrengend sie noch anstrengen
okay weil dann ist die ganze zeit
okay ich bin lange schon so ein bisschen
müde ich muss wieder meine energie
sammeln
hier sind meine sachen gerade gekauft
haben und wir stehen jetzt schon in der
nähe von reinigen studio gehen da jetzt
gleich rein und ich glaube dann führt
kein weg vorbei sich erstmal zu
betrinken und dann zu singen also ich
habe glaube ich noch nie von der kamera
gesungen oder generell noch nie richtig
mich angestrengt und da vor der kamera
gesungen hast du schon wirklich ja
wandern freddys party meine in stara
stimmt okay da waren wir aber auch
getrunken
wir gehen erst mal rein da habe ich auch
schon ein paar mal getroffen habe kannst
du nicht so gut aber es wird bestimmt
lustig
[Musik]
das geht nach erlebt und kennst du ja
das schon ganz brav durch ein neues
plakat neben nicht dass ich einmal darum
dass man nochmals das hier ist dass man
überstand so anziehen
ihr habt ihr champagner ich konnte
irgendwie am sabbat zu teuer deswegen
haben wir keinen sport
aber ich finde es ganz schlecht das geht
echt unklar ist sie daraufhin
verschiedene und aber passt das jetzt zu
dem was wir machen
ich glaube ich selbst an dessen was du
mit mir vor hast also wir können das ich
bin talent darin dass in die richtung zu
drehen dass es passt da müssen wir so
ich krieg das auf jeden fall so hin dass
das passt vielleicht können wir ja was
macht ihr denn normalerweise mit kenne
hier
wir haben einige sachen schon
veröffentlicht ja wir haben ja vor klick
wechselspiel das war also ihr eigenes
ding sagt aber auch super alter egos zb
will ja ok diesen treffer marktlage
haben wir dich geschlagen weil ammann
mäßig gut dass man jemand anders redet
ich bin die ganze zeit so wären sonst
wäre ich bin ja so haben flocken und ich
komme damit gar nicht gleichwertig hab
heut scho glaube ich drei stunden
videomaterial aufgenommen oder so und
ich dachte echt so dass mich der schlag
trifft so dass ich das die adresse bei
google eingeben sondern weisen waxing
studio
das war übrigens ihre idee gehabt
irgendetwas alkoholisiert für kate schon
mal eben verschwistert das kannst du
hier unten
jeder hat der küchenhersteller haben
sind energieeffizienz
na gut dann wir besprechen habe ich mal
ein bisschen und dann fangen wir gleich
alles das ist eine app von meinem auto
und hier steht dass das fahrzeug
entriegelt ist das heißt was zur hölle
macht kette gerade mit meinem auto dem
ich vor einer stunde angerufen was die
gerade fahren und jetzt das auto
irgendwo entriegelt und besser schaut
mal bei kelly vorbei und zu sehen was
sie mit meinem auto machen leute ich
habe von ihm gehört was er vor hat er
scheinbar einen trap beat das passt
natürlich perfekt zu meinem aktuellen
outfit ich bin keine alexander marcus
der treff szene und scheint man muss
sich selbst schreiben also ich muss mir
selbst ein text überlegen weil kelly das
immer machen das richtig gut als
nächstes hören wir uns dass man zusammen
an den beat oder ok bin gespannt
die deutschen das hier mal freunde was
ist das bitte für ein raumschiff dieses
studio man hat glaube ich auch direkt
wie gut die akustik ist nicht einfach
aus das heißt ein porsche design oder so
die akustik elemente muss irgendwie
nochmal meine kumpels fragen auf die
irgendwelche ideen haben was ich da
schreiben kann oder sowas oder darf ich
das überhaupt nach der challenge ich
muss auch mal was essen leute ich habe
heute bisher nur das stück von katys
kuchen gegessen also langsam wird es
zeit dass mal was essen wir haben da
asiatisches essen bestellt weil die
linken harry mit mir es ist die nur
asiatische ganz genau und ich haben
schon aufgegessen ich habe es leider
nicht geschafft das ist eigentlich
keiner will es war sehr lecker und
gleich wie wir dann also schreiben ohne
witz ich habe das gefühl ich glaube ich
fühle mich so als wäre ich vielleicht
nicht so super schlecht darin so ein
song zu covern also etwas einfach
nachzumachen aber selbst was zu machen
ist glaube ich so schwer und wir sind
uns auch noch nicht ganz sicher über das
thema vielleicht wird es entweder ein
song aus kellys perspektive sowie toll
kelly ist also ich bin ja es wird einen
lovesong überquert mal ein lied über wie
schön das internet ist und es wurde es
von euch weggenommen
nikes noch im artikel bereits in rage du
hast schon etwas vorbereitet meinst du
ich dachte was traffic ist damit er
nicht singen mussten wir das zur sprache
das ist lieb von dir schon mal ja sonst
wäre es vielleicht zu schwer geworden
und noch mal gucken wie es hier wird
vielleicht kriegen wir noch einige sagen
sicher ob die leute egal was jetzt
passiert nimmt es nicht zu ernst oder
ich habe einen lustigen anzug an das
heißt alles was ich tue ist ironisch und
legitimiert genug gechillt und jetzt
geht es daran dass ich wirklich was
schreibe willst du mal den beat eben an
machen wissen wir wohin wir arbeiten los
geht's
[Musik]
das klingt doch russell crowe erzählen
warum spricht nur die thematik
emotionales draufkommt okay leute meine
aufgabe ist jetzt irgendwelche punkte
wir haben uns entschieden ich mache so
ein
fanny liebestrank elli und als erstes
schreibe ich mir mal so viele sachen an
kelly auf die irgendwie lustig sind und
sie vielleicht gut auch so auch sowas
passen
ok ich lese dir mal vor was nicht so
haben vielleicht hast du ja auch ideen
erst mal ihr gerollt ist er dann harry
potter ganz wichtig die haare von nike
also hier youtube legendenstatus aber
das also klar das sind nur so grundideen
leute ist es hier und das ist wirklich
alles andere als einfach ich hätte
gedacht dass das irgendwie so haben wie
schwer kann schon sein so was zu
schreiben aber ich bin gerade richtig
sinn sondern dass diese form überlegen
bin ich habe so eine idee schon wie ich
vielleicht irgendwie so diese hocke
melodie machen kann also ich wollte
niemals einen youtube song machen aber
ich meine ich machen ich bin ja ich
fühle mich gerade so schlecht für jeden
youtuber den ich immer so gehalten habe
ich habe wir haben jemanden so gewesen
aber dass sie so machst du musik
du hast bestimmt auch noch ganz viel
input ich sammle gerade so gedanken über
so eigenschaften von kelly haare von
nike das hat nicht mal für miami
was reimt auf bayern war der mord nicht
tanzverbot ich muss tanzen gehen kannst
verbot bringen aber will ich das schaffe
kelly muss zumindest nicht genauso viel
wie ich sie beim autofahren
wahrscheinlich ist nicht das ist mein
aktueller ansatz bier um irgendwie mit
diesem komischen moment klar zu kommen
ja bis auf eineinhalb stunden da und
habe mir zwei von diesen versus überlegt
und ich muss wirklich an der stelle
einfach mal sagen großen respekt an alle
leute auch wenn es nur youtube musik ist
es ist wirklich viel schwerer als man
denkt auch vielen danke für deine geduld
ich bin als absoluter nook hier
eingegangen und werde auch alles wieder
verlassen als absoluter lob also
erwartet nichts wir fangen jetzt an dass
aufzunehmen und ich weiß alles so drehen
das ist dass man das ist nicht mal
auffällt dass du bist oder warst wenn
das so ist dann dann bin ich mal
gespannt ob kiew gucken wir mal das ist
mein gott für das musikvideo o mein gott
was muss ich die einzige möglichkeit das
durchzuziehen trinken mehr alkohol
kinder morgens mittags abends auf das
vertrittst du ein video in der 1
natürlich treffen so richtig direkt rein
reden ja also halte ich das am besten so
dass er gerollt die rolex gold auch hier
zwischen update wir haben zwei parts
aufgenommen und mikey schläft einfach 21
uhr ist eine gute uhr zum schlafen auf
jeden fall was sagst du dazu
nein ich habe schon gesehen ja ein
bisschen meine weit ball modus verlassen
hemd aus der hose geholt und so und dann
ging es auch ein bisschen besser gehen
wir müssen uns jetzt noch eine überlegen
nachdem wir die papst jetzt fertig oder
ein angefangen sind sie fertig oder
angefangen dann müssen wir uns jetzt nur
noch um die hoch kümmern ich denke ich
habe das produkt gerade schon gehört ich
werde euch ich weiß nicht genau wann ich
zeige aber ich muss wirklich sagen ich
bin sehr positiv überrascht großes lob
an dicht dran aber auch richtig mir das
war so ein ereignisreicher tag ich werde
auch gleich meine wohnung begeben
natürlich in den fünften stock ohne
aufzug eigentlich so lange mit uns hier
bis wir nach hause fahren und wir fahren
sie dann immer nach hause
achso auf dem weg nach hause gefahren
kurzen umweg von fernsehen das klingt
nicht schlecht aber okay dann werde ich
mir das sehr gut
ja keine ahnung also wir haben jetzt
hier so fünf stunden an dem song
gearbeitet und es ist halt so voll der
youtube star geworden aber ja ich bin
schon gespannt wenn ich zeige aber ich
glaube das muss sich gesondert machen
dass er gerade die rolex golf volk und
ich rede von kelly die haare sind sofern
sie sie sind von nike die rahmen ist
sie macht die mails direkt von ihrem
schreibtisch weil sie so nice und ihr
kleid selbst steht auch sie jetzt dieser
kilian heinrich vielleicht ist bisschen
peinlich aber ich glaub ich hab mich
verguckt weil ich immer daran denken
muss
sie ist eine youtube die kinder und ihre
rollen so schön ich denke an sie ohne
ende
dann werde ich wieder sie in die politik
cep den ohrläppchen man jetzt wieder sie
in die politik und ohrläppchen war werde
ich sie wiedersehen ich bin der tanks zu
deiner lilly potter tanzverbot du bist
ein opfer opfer
ich kam zu dir mittmann koffer in
deutschland heißt es heidi und in
österreich hofer fun fact das war den
random light
kelly ist legende so wie hänschen klein
zu aber ich glaub ich hab mich verguckt
weil ich immer daran denken muss
sie ist die youtube die kinder
roth ihre ohrläppchen so schön ich denke
an sie ohne ende
dann werde ich wieder sehen die politik
den ohrläppchen halle wieder den
ohrläppchen ohrläppchen war werde ich
sie wiedersehen dann werde ich sie
wiedersehen die ohrläppchen ohrläppchen
ohrläppchen bahn werde ich sie wieder
freunde da bin ich eine 43 bin umgestylt
mit gewächsen hahn und habe gerade einen
song aufgenommen
also wirklich jetzt der tag man einfach
so krass ereignisreich glaube ich muss
einfach jetzt echt mal kennen gehen
morgen gucke ich mich auf jeden fall
noch mal bevor ich zurückgehe ganz
ausführlich hier in der wohnung rum bin
mega fertig aber ich bin richtig happy
es war ein geiler tag und ich kann es
selbst überhaupt nicht erwarten dieses
video zu sehen wenn es fertig ist und so
hast du ja kurz sagen jetzt erst mal ein
komisches outfit aus dann sehen wir uns
[Musik]